he's the ruler of dubai but stands
accused of breaking british law the high
court ruling sheikh muhammad al maktoum
ordered the phones of his ex-wife and
her lawyers to be hacked in an ongoing
custody battle taking place in the uk
it found princess heyer and her
barrister the conservative peer baroness
shackleton had their phones targeted by
multi-million pound spyware called
pegasus a program manufactured by an
israeli company the nso group and sold
exclusively to nation states
usually i'm used to investigating
surveillance against journalists and
dissidents this is kind of the first
time that i saw uh or you know what i
thought was basically government spyware
being used
potentially against someone's ex-wife
and their lawyers in a child custody
case
the hacking came to light via a chain of
connections involving sherry blair the
wife of former british prime minister
tony blair was an adviser to nso and
contacted baroness shackleton about the
potential surveillance after being told
the pegasus software may have been
misused
it can be used to take over a person's
entire device and that means that it can
pull all of the data off even encrypted
messaging
it can be used to covertly activate a
microphone a camera and the really
troubling thing is that you would
probably never know about it the case
being heard here on the surface is
intensely personal it's a divorce battle
over custody of two children but these
latest judgments stretch well beyond the
personal sphere described by the court
as being serial breaches of uk law and
an abuse of power to a significant
extent
sheikh mohammed who offered no evidence
to the court said i have always denied
the allegations made against me and i
continue to do so the findings were
based on evidence that was not disclosed
to me or my advisors i therefore
maintain that they were made in a manner
which was unfair
it's not the first time the sheikh has
been the focus of a damning ruling from
the high court last year it found the 72
year old orchestrated the abduction and
forced return to dubai of two of his
daughters sheikha latifah and sheikha
shamsa and now this close ally of
britain is facing further questions over
how far he attempts to exert his power
iva bennett sky news